ligue 1 se sent comme un poisson dans
l'eau dans cette campagne en plein hiver
un projet qu'elle vient de lancer ici à
plus d'une heure de route de toronto la
ville où elle a passé toute sa vie
depuis sa naissance une ville qui
grouillaient de monde et d'activités
jusqu il y a un an
cette femme qui a enseigné
l'anthropologie à l'université n'a
jamais eu peur du changement
la preuve il y a dix ans elle s'est
tournée vers la gestion d'un peuple
torontois
[Musique]
mais son commerce a dû fermer il y a
maintenant un an
évidemment à cause de la coved et la
blessure n'est pas encore cicatrisées
toronto c'est ici que la nouvelle vie
commence pour lise dans ses vastes
espaces une idée a germé dans son esprit
d'abord quitter la ville terrassé par la
pandémie et la solitude et autour du feu
s'est jointe la belle-mère de lise qui
possède une terre de 9 hectares
et bientôt des carottes des légumes de
toutes sortes et des herbes
ces apprentis maraîchers vont commencer
par planter un hectare le rêve se
concrétise de jour en jour avant même de
planter quoi que ce soit
ben eager s'est plongé dans les livres
pour apprendre ce nouveau métier avec
son esprit d'entrepreneur en vendant des
cartes de membres de son futur
gigantesque potager et ça marche
pour l'anthropologue et ex tenancière de
bar ce nouveau départ se fait aussi
grâce à la communauté du coin ou
l'entr'aide est très forte et toronto
donc tout ça il n'y aura pas de retour
en arrière
l'aco vide a vraiment changé sa vie
le couple continue de rêver à ces chants
qui bientôt seront couverts de légumes
et de fruits
ce ne sera pas rose tous les jours mais
une chose est sûre pour lise grâce à la
pandémie et l'a fait le bon choix